not enough for me gory yeah what might
you it's just gory
but so before we were filming cats going
on a uh scary movie
what would you call it like you're just
going down the rabbit hole yeah
going down the rabbit hole i want to
binge a bunch of scary movies right now
and what have you done so far the
conjurings
uh sinister insidious we're starting
right now
sinister one and two yeah one answer
both solid great the first one was my
favorite sinister
ethanol first one's top five scary
movies of all time absolutely
uh we a few months ago i did the
american horror stories we did the
haunted that haunting show on netflix
haunting of
like hill house yes i did blind second
season
second season as [ __ ] um what else
i also thought you did american horror
story yeah i did america
was it like 10 seasons something like
that yeah the new season is coming out
uh this is wednesday
it looks good it looks good everyone i
i've heard uh
mixed opinions everyone says the 1987
one's like the best
scene that's stevie's favorite yeah
because they don't have the nightstand
is that the first it has the night
stalkers there's like
two two seasons okay did you see the
with the covenant the witch
coven cutman's good apocalypse was good
one word house is great
uh do you see the one where lady gaga
and it's basically based off the
hotel yeah you know it's a cecil hotel
then yeah
that's why you filmed it there that one
gets a little weird yeah it gets a
little weird here and there but
it's did you see the the circus season
yeah that one i didn't get into
as much i was kind of like that was good
the clown was
[ __ ] terrible the clown is based off
of like a real serial killer right
uh yeah that's basically casey yeah john
williams there you go
psychopath fat guy kill people put him
in the basement uh
trying to think what else you could
watch oh it's the one i told you with
joe mchale
uh delivers from evil yeah uh deliver
us from evil with eric bana in it yes
top five
that's a great uh wait what's the texas
chainsaw the with jessica biel
jeepers creepers you were saying earlier
not too scary but that's not scary but
it's uh yeah it's entertaining it's good
for like
what it is what about the sauce you're
going down the salt tonight oh the sauce
takes forever to get through oh hostels
hostels i don't think i've heard of that
one you're seeing hostile one or two
so scary well i shouldn't say it's scary
because it happens in real life
hostiles bother me because that could
really go down
those are the ones that keep me up at
night see those are the scary movies
these bother me because people really do
this in the world
where they paint where they paint like
yeah and foreign countries are paid to
murder people stuff
so they're more scared from paranormal
stuff really
uh the first one got me if well if
there's like a
paranormal activity no no no not
paranormal activity i meant like parents
yeah like spirit like real ghost stuff
yeah oh you know it was
uh uh what was it called what was the
first like
um god what was that [ __ ] movie the
very first one
where we thought it was real blair blair
witch yeah blair witch
i saw him in high school i was so scared
and then we because we thought it was
real remember they're like they got real
footage
this ghost and if you go if i would have
went into it known
it was fake it's terrible hands down
the worst movie i ever [ __ ] made but
going to the thing it was real we got
out like
yeah and they had where they couldn't
say anything after the movie came out so
people thought it was a real
foundational situation yeah they tried
to make a number two didn't they they
they made a few yeah mm-hmm last few
years they came out they're trying to
run it back again
yeah not the same thing though it's not
real no no no
not real come on but everyone ever that
was like the big thing everyone did
think it was real
that but that's the only reason it
worked yeah so nighttime so i was a
sophomore in high school
i remember driving to some theater
downtown denver we were [ __ ]
terrified
literally a week later came out that was
fake we're like well that's the worst
moment we've ever seen
it's it must cost seven dollars to make
it's based off
and they're like running through the
force like this and [ __ ]
i'm trying to think what else you could
watch as far as scary goes
oh the collection's really good or is it
the collector
it's one of the two collectors yeah that
one was good the butterflies and [ __ ]
yeah that's the collector
that one's really good uh i love scary
movies
yeah if i told you recommendations let
me know oh what's it called what's the
one i told you to watch
it's like gin yeah great that one is
always amazing one bedroom apartment
fantastic
it must been so cheap to make there's
some special effects but literally
oh it just stays there the only scene is
in a one-bedroom apartment this dad's
like all right i'm going to do the night
shift and leaves his son
and then his son's just got to deal with
all this and it's on it's so good
you haven't watched that either huh the
kid's half korean dude i'll watch
a lot he's half white half cream and you
won't watch it
damn i can't recommend it enough my name
too dude yeah
it has like a 99 on rotten tomatoes all
right because
you know we i ran of uh iran of watching
[ __ ] yellowstone you know what's
coming back in november
[ __ ] you paramount november
dude every [ __ ] june a new season
drops november
that's insulting dude it's [ __ ] so
it's oh yellowstone
season four yellowstone so we're ready
to get a riot
i'm thinking about it i'm definitely not
wearing like oh cowboy hat until it
comes out
but um what so we ran out [ __ ] to watch
wouldn't have yellowstone
so i literally just googled like
top-rated movie on amazon and jyn
came up 99 like approval all right i was
like
99 i think he's probably lame as [ __ ]
dude it was
so i'm hyping it but remember i had no
hype going to i was like check it out it
was [ __ ]
it's new new right pretty new i'll watch
it tonight and then i'll watch the
the new one which is good new grudge is
worth watching new growth better than
the first one
really way better oh wow that one's
pretty scary yeah that's the one where
the
girl comes out of the tv right yeah
that's the ring no that one's the ring
the grudge is the
girl and the they're in japan right here
yeah yeah yeah i've seen that one
i've seen that one and there's a lot of
scary moves we're not mentioning that
korea
and like japan they they own the like
horror movie market
they really do yeah they do horror
relationships it's like normal stuff
yeah
there's a new saw with chris rock oh
yeah i haven't watched that one yet
chin pull up gin it's how just d right
no
dj g j i n g i think it's a remake of an
old one but god it's good
no c c o j i n n n d d
i n and the gin
but that looks kind of that's this no
he's not in it okay
why's always pop up i was like what is
this ninja turtles dog
that's a white walker he's not in it is
this one in it
uh yes that's it oh no that says english
arabic
no and 2013 too oh she's in it right
there 2021 right there she's in it
holy [ __ ] that's his mom spoiler oh
my gosh it's so good though i think i
might get i think i might give it a
chance
i'm telling you i think i might give it
a chance
a little nervous but i'll give it a
chance what'd you say i said i'll watch
it with you all right let's watch it
first uh who's single in here
here's a little tip for you guys well
not for you don't no i don't want you to
go down this route
christian has a single man you know if
you take a girl one of your dates to a
scary movie like a legit scary movie
when people men and women when they get
scared they give off the same endorphins
as
when they're sexually aroused yeah
trauma bonding that's really what it is
oh my bad i figure you're taking your
date to [ __ ] the avengers or
something
you're crying when ironman dies and [ __ ]
that's for me what were you saying i
should avoid scary movies that's what
you're saying if a kid's like
if you if some young man's like hey the
new saul's coming out let's go to it you
know he's looking for one thing one
thing only yeah unless you've got an
endorphin to bond with you unless you
really like him
if you've been on a few dates yeah but
if he's like giving away like he's a
creep if he's like hey girl i got this
foot long broadway thing you can handle
that you're like what
he's like oh well i just got tickets to
the new saul you're like foot long hot
dogs
saul creep creeps
yeah and this is me helping you as a
friend
yeah he's being he's being real [ __ ]
nice right now
now have you gone on dates out here no
actually been chilling her dad listening
to the show so no
oh yeah he does probably oh
so the answer is hell no how dare you
hey jack uh
christian was the uh star fight
companion by accident
[Laughter]
no idea huh no idea i had no [ __ ]
every well kevin the film crew was like
no we're good
they won't be in the shot so i'm like
cool man so you know we did fight pants
yeah it went great
it looked great it went great looking
amazing so much fun
literally i forgot how much fun i that
it's my favorite [ __ ] show to do
but uh christian's in the back the
entire time
eating and fight with like his feet up
chilling
the entire time i was
so invested in the fights i didn't know
i was on camera so you see
so you can't really see but behind
bradley and josh is a uh
curtain like okay yep you can't really
see but it's a curtain you'll seem to
have that go all the way around now
okay so it looks like so it doesn't see
all the this looks like an office and
everyone's chilling like organizing [ __ ]
yeah there it is oh they're
gonna bring that all the way around now
it looks dope though looks amazing that
was great
we got the whiskey's out had some
whiskeys made some bats
snacks and cody are on shroom so that's
cool
oh these are sure micro dose
oh so they're just chilling yeah they're
they're stevie in the back like
everyone's just chilling
stevie with that beard stevie's eyes it
looks like he's crying at all times now
it does look like i forgot he had eye
issues and i was like uh maybe him and
kagan
well yeah did they fix that yet or why
are both eyes right
because the is he doing drops of some
[ __ ] no i don't know what's going
on he needs to go back to the doctor but
he refuses so i don't know i'm trying to
convince him doctor suck
yeah i don't know but it is
i was talking to the team and they're
like all right what should we do
different next time
and they're like can we suggest
something uh so you just have people in
the back
like i was like who's in the back like
christian like no way like he's like
snacking back there
vaping and [ __ ] you forget how young
so he gets there right and it's it's
josh uh
myself josh thompson bradley martin cody
garbett we're all just sitting right
we're about to go live
yeah chris comes and goes fellas gotta
ask before we start
predictions christian was all up in the
videos
bro we got a show to do man we're not
breaking this down for you
i was just so starship like i mean like
seeing all them there like i wanted to
yeah hey you you shoot your shots man
you really do
you shoot your shots he's shot man
oh you and you know what we're going to
do what i'm thinking just as we're going
through it sorry i'm going to wrap you
up
next time i want you to have the audio
and you so you'll be here and watching
the fights
so then you can be like hey sugar sean
cody or
rogan said this or dc said this or and i
said so you can let us know what's going
on i have that in the air and i have the
audio on this here yeah so tv and i also
have a
just headphones for the tv audio so you
guys can put on whatever you know what
i'm saying
i don't want that because then because
depending who it is they'll be
distracted
you know what i'm saying if we're just
listening then no one's talking okay if
you're just listening them talk there's
no reason
for us to talk yeah so i don't want to
trip any
access to the audio okay just video
you'll have access audio
that's what would change all right
that's the last week in the studio
last week last week if brian johnson
gets the studio done
and if all the furniture arrives it got
came today but nobody was there so
that's cool
oh that's a bummer i know the new set's
gonna be dope though
chin's seen it things are coming along
it's a beast yeah
it's a beast that's dope as [ __ ] yeah
it's gonna be cool man
we're driving down here [ __ ] hour
every day for last three now we headed
to calabasas say what's up to drake
along the way
what's up man you know took a right yeah
took her right
at the light i forget how it goes ah
she's in love with who i am
back in the house drake went on a date
oh bro
how about that hey drake how about you
quit
[ __ ] up for the rest of this listen
man y'all [ __ ] around if you're
sleeping on
any old regular mattress because
nobody's built like you nobody is built
like
you so i sleep on a mattress built for
everybody helix
is changing the game helix sleep has a
quiz takes just two minutes to complete
matches your body type
and sleep preferences to the perfect
mattress just for your
thick ass with your side sleeper hot
sleeper
plush firm with helix there's no more
confusion all right we got you covered
helix sleep was even awarded number one
best overall mattress
pick of 2019 2020 by gq and wired
magazine
i have at my cribs i've had it for years
it's the best mattress it's gonna be
good for several years
friends hit me up about it family
friends everybody wants to stay at my
crib just because i have these
mattresses
so go to helixleep.com take their two
minute sleep quiz
they will match you with a perfect
customized mattress just for you to give
you the best sleep of your life
they have a 10-year warranty you get to
try out for 100 nights risk free
they even pick it up if you don't love
it but you well so don't worry about
that helix is offering you guys up to
200
off all mattress orders and free pillows
for the listeners of firing the kid and
viewers helix sleep.com
fighter that's helix sleep.com fighter
for up to 200
off hey kids you know two out of three
men will experience
some form of hair loss by the time
they're 35 more than
50 million bros in the us suffer from
male pattern baldness
there are only two fda approved
medications that can prevent hair loss
and my friends at keeps offers
both that's right keeps offers a simple
stress
free way to keep your hair all you got
to do
is you have to talk to a doc and the
medication delivers straight to your
door every three months
so you never have to leave the crib low
cost treatments start just 10
per month keeps offers generic versions
discreet low package
proven results keeps has more than five
star reviews
more than any of its competitors
prevention is key
keep what you have right now man don't
wait till your hair is gone
and you're bald treatments can take four
to six months to see results so act
right now
if you're ready take action prevent hair
loss go to keps.com
fighter to receive your first month's
free of treatment for free
that's dot com keeps keps.com to get
your first month's free keeps.com slash
fighter
about drake went on a date oh bro how
about you guys
oh my god hey drake how about you quit
[ __ ] up for the rest of this
yeah there's like five guys in the world
he could rent out [ __ ] dodgers
he didn't even mean to let people know
though some guy was just flying over
dude
oh he knows jacob knows what he's doing
that means ratted on him because it's
weird that they just fly over an empty
statement
and her son plays at sierra canyon
calling him out because a few days after
he went on that date with that baddie
he was on nicki minaj's uh instagram
live and he was texting her like hey the
girl you have
on your live with you she's a singer
named bia bad as [ __ ]
he was like oh she's a baddie she's cute
and nicki minaj called him out on her
live saying like go back to your big
booty ting
so people calling him out for like
hitting on another girl
let drake drink you know who the [ __ ]
rents out dodger stadium
drake but i guess it was it wasn't him
being like hey i'll pay whatever
and have a date there i guess he made a
donation to the dodgers so like hey if
you ever
want to have a private dinner here and
he was like all right i'll use it now on
this big titty girl
mm-hmm big everything yeah big
everything she looks she looks
big like yeah she's like very like a
tall curve you know her son's the number
one basketball player yeah ucla right
he's going to ucla
drake uh he jake's got pictures of him
on his instagram yeah yes they were
saying drake's helping out with his
financial and
i'm like but she used to date an nba
player oh she's like helping the kid get
somewhere
oh here look at josh what josh post
there
your new life is going to cost you your
old one
terrible that's fine can you live
[Laughter]
it's okay is this you commenting yeah
put uh
i put the asterisk and put thick put the
asterisk
that yep that's it perfect so anyways
that kid's a senior this year isn't it
he's going to use
his ucla for a baller a baller is he
better than braun
lebron oh yeah oh she's better than
lebron but what's interesting she's
doing an nba player and obviously
some player i've never heard of she was
he was the nba player was obviously
helping the kid get to wherever he's you
know
with his basketball group that's the kid
right and then drake shows up mm-hmm
yeah that's the kid
yeah it's tall and they're clearly at
dave and buster's so that's
just [ __ ] chill isaac drake always on
that
hookah if who can [ __ ] i think if you
agree
if you rent it out you can do whatever
the [ __ ] you want if you're drake yeah
god he is everything he's [ __ ] living
i tried bringing a hookah in the green
room they're like get the [ __ ] out
make sense i'll go back to my drawing
board yeah i mean dave lucas love that
go uh
click on that that kid's profile you see
his mom
let's see what you think chen she's
super yeah i don't think she's gonna
find i'll see what chad thinks
i bet he don't post his mom dude it must
be tough it must be tough for that kid
it must be really tough for that kid
because when your mom's a [ __ ]
dime and she but she's not like this guy
that keeps it like no she'll wear like
baggy sweaters
yeah yeah yeah she's housing oh it must
be for he got the whole get up
yeah it must be challenging when that's
your mom yeah you know your boys are
like doug but also he ain't mad that
drake's
she's probably low-key hype yeah he's
like oh [ __ ] jack's gonna be my stepdad
he's
like mom how was that date it's also
awkward though yeah
he's fine he's living kind of though but
it's also your mom so like drake comes
over at like midnight
oh i thought i was gonna see you
tomorrow he's like yeah i'll see you
tomorrow we were just at dave and
buzzers yeah we were i'm here to
see
like a ucla basketball player he's
probably out somewhere else
i think he's at home at midnight what
she's banging no no i
i think she's banging you do yeah she is
she's gorgeous how old is she
old enough to be a mom of a 20 year old
20 year old yeah so she's oh she has to
be at least
damn near 38 i bet yeah it says 40.
40. i don't know how legit that is but
64. i think she's pretty sure she's four
dude that's a grown
[ __ ] woman yeah
that is a woman dog that is
dude she is super pretty so she's just
famous because she went out with drake
no so she said she's hot as [ __ ]
christians
and then drake noticed her and was like
hey you're hot as [ __ ] and now they went
on a date at jesus christ they went on a
date at [ __ ] uh
doctor stadium good lord i'm not gonna
lie to you guys my girl has
damn near the same body i'm not gonna
don't mean to fly don't mean to fly flex
no flex
she she looks taller but like a
pretty similar body which is fantastic
looks on that that is what the world
knows bomb
nice photoshop very pixelated legs baby
thank you man mini figgies understand
region yeah
meanwhile he's just jacking off her
that's usually how it goes
god yeah dawg get it out of my face man
what are you trying to do man yeah it
has to be one more one more
one more [ __ ] that's your mom that has
to be challenging man yeah that
but it's drake oh you know who i saw
this weekend i took uh tiger to the
malibu car show
yeah i saw those bigs they looked
amazing dude it looked like he was
having a blast yeah it's
every sunday they do that malibu car
show there but yeah jay leno jerry
seinfeld
spike they're all there with their cars
so who do you see
uh jay leno and jason yeah all all the
big boys are there
cars are ridiculous this is what bothers
me about uh
tiger is he loves uh lamborghinis oh
is it heartbreaking well i keep like
even when we were walking up i'm he's
like he had like lamborghinis were
pulling in
he's like dad look at lamborghini i'm
like yeah yeah listen dude so
lamborghinis are cool they're cool if
you're a youtuber but
if you're your dad and your grandpa and
your brother we're a porsche family
so you're by nature you're gonna be a
porsche guy so notice i make them take
pictures
yeah that green one goes hard as far as
that's a gunther i think that is painful
i'm not a big into those little cars
that one's custom made yeah this oh wow
700 grand car all custom yeah they take
them and remodel them
but uh so he's like let's look at the
lambos like jesus christ dude get over
lambos but they look like hot wheels so
for a kid you can see why they like them
but i'm telling about like how porsche
is different and how ferrari's different
lamborghini are you hoping this is a
lambo phase
i'm hoping all kids kind of like that's
like the car right because yeah they
look like [ __ ]
tonka toys but uh i was talking my
friend was there and he has a
he had alfa romero and uh a porsche he
had a poor shirt on i'm talking to him
and i didn't know this is how smart kids
are i'm talking to him and he goes oh
what are you guys looking at my god
my kids in the [ __ ] lamborghinis man
so you're like cruise by the lambo
section
take pictures and [ __ ] i was like i'm
trying to get him off that kick of
lamborghini he's like gotta come most
kids like lambos because they look all
crazy
i'm like i know but he's seen my car
like every car we see you go dad's that
fashion in a car i go no
how's that fashion car go no literally
there's like maybe
one car two cars there fast in my car
every single car is that fashion crowd
no
all the lambos no no no no you don't
give a [ __ ]
i why i didn't know is he hurt like he
was off like looking at the tires
whatever
touching the cars putting his [ __ ]
sticky hands all over the cars
we're back in the car he was dad i just
want you to know this lamborghini thing
isn't a phase
and i'm always going to like
lamborghinis even though you and grandpa
like porsches
i'm like holy [ __ ] you heard that he's
like i heard that damn
damn bro he'd be listening i know man
kids pick up he don't [ __ ] around
but that car show's fantastic man he
talks like jay
yeah super argumentative
super argumentative yeah look at him
there
he looks so cute man look at it yeah he
loved it that horse is insane though
uh there's a the the that one's insane
go keep going chin
you're rocking a chain he has a ch it
says t on it he want to be like his dad
that is not real gold so don't steal my
picture
uh but that's a porsche r behind them
that that thing's super valuable yeah
that that's better than that green one
uh different oh it's just different
different yeah that that green one's
literally that's one of one like
if you have a gunther i have a friend
who just got a gun there's the most
ridiculous porsche you've ever seen so
there's a singer
who does it but they're kind of like a i
love singer but they're kind of like a
hype
porsche modded company and then
gunther's like dude
dude like so they're not like that green
one you're not
if you buy that you're the only one with
that that's why i love it so if you get
a singer you're the only one with that
so that yeah that's why
yeah that's why you get down with all
that stuff oh my god it's just because
a lot of it's rarity and then you're
then you're picking everything from the
stitching on the seats
yeah to the the dials to the stick shift
to the
the rugs the everything everything i
used to be in the audi r8s
those are dope they they still are yeah
i used to be they see they're basically
lamborghinis audio and xiaomi
they put the same engine in the audi
right they do oh really yeah oh okay
same engine
the great cars yeah rainbows are great
too it's just not my cup of tea
hey i don't fit in the single
lamborghini so i hate them and i was
trying to tell tayden i'm like dude
you're going to be too big for lambs
when you get older and also you need to
find it oh damn
you know what that cost i tell him he's
like is that more than fifty dollars
like
yes it's more than fifty dollars dude i
like that one that'd be great that'd be
my style
i could see in that yeah that'd be dope
well actually they don't have the stick
yeah they're not yeah they have the but
you can cool you can still do that
no the uh yeah they have the title
shifters than this
they don't have it's either you go up or
down yeah that's what they have
yeah and that's actually better yeah the
computer is faster than you and of all
the times i valet because i i pass up
every [ __ ]
one of those like fast small cars that
one i was actually like
no howdy interiors i was like let me i
was like let me drive that one yeah
they're set i like that one
they're really dope but yeah that malibu
uh
car shows i've never been i've heard so
much about it and then me and tiger
he was going crazy inside i'm like dude
let's go this [ __ ] car show i've
never been so we drove down there
she drank all the soda and touched all
the cars you let him drink soda
very rare oh okay you want to see he can
have a day yeah you know
yeah it's like with my fitness pal dog
when i tell about my fitness pal you
stand under
uh 1800 what are you doing
how many calories we want doug so the
way fitness pal works is you entering
you're basically tracking your macros
yeah all your macros and how many
calories because if you don't it won't
get out of hand
yes it and i was really out of hand
you're getting pretty big papa
i know yeah so i i it's at 2 500.
that's what you yeah what what should i
do i would love it i don't i don't even
get to you 25 you don't do
you don't what do you get i never i
never hit 2500.
i usually have like eight or 900 left
that's good yeah that's usually what i
have left
i didn't realize how hard it was like to
get to the
it's not if like if you ate you know
well i mean it was pretty easy before
like if you just have like you know when
my kids want chick-fil-a i'm like [ __ ]
there goes my dinner you know or like
i'm having a crouton for dinner because
like 1200 calories for chick-fil-a
also you get the fries if you have a
sandwich at chick-fil-a it'll tell you
600. it'll tell you on the my fitness
pal like hey
this has a lot of sodium sodium got a
track though yeah
isn't it great though oh that's a live
change but i've been doing it now for
over four weeks but eventually you just
like i still
attract some things if it's like a new
thing i'm gonna eat but i usually kind
of eat the similar stuff
yeah so i kind of stay in there
those uh premier protein shakes that you
do bro
i'm changing my life with the food are
you losing weight yeah i think i'm
probably
uh i don't know maybe two pounds you
know still
i just started like when i start dude if
you did two pounds
a week like four weeks what's up yeah
sorry yeah i've been doing it four weeks
in a month
what'd you say eight pounds in a month
that's good huge oh yeah and
when you complete your logging to tell
you if you keep eating this way you'll
uh for in five weeks you'll would you
buy the premiere
no it was just a regular mine doesn't do
that it doesn't no that'd be nice you
have to use a free trial for that
you'll probably have the free trial i
don't have a free trial because i have
the free trial and it does that for me
really track your calories christian
yeah yours should just be eat whatever
well i'm trying that's why i do it i try
to like
what do you what do you have is set to
what twenty nine hundred twenty one
higher bubba
well i usually hit him it'll be like i'm
at like five years
2900 yeah he's trying to gain weight
though i know but
with your body you can hit 2 900. yeah i
do i drink like
slices of pizza yeah i just ate a whole
salad the other day nah nah i don't like
doing
ton of tuna no no whole box of pizza
[Laughter]
oh i got into that magic spoon cereal do
you like it
[ __ ] sakes hey i got i got an extra box
for you what flavor though what do you
like
i like the fruity and i like the frosted
oh okay so i got the fruity and the
peanut butter
you don't like the peanut butter try the
peanut butter you haven't tried the
fruity and the frosting the fruit bruh i
don't know about magic spoons
oh i don't know about it because i hear
so many people get sponsored by them
i've never heard of it and then our boy
mark obviously is fitness freak
that's how i found out he was like it's
like protein cereal use this
yeah it's like basically zero carbs zero
sugar might be three grams i am high in
protein yeah yeah like 16 grams of
protein yeah a little bit higher protein
magic
the frosted tastes almo 110 calories in
a [ __ ] bowl
uh 11 grams of protein 110 calories 1
grams of protein 10 carbs
0 grams of sugar dude the [ __ ] cookie
tastes just like captain crunch
no no i'm telling you because you
haven't had it i haven't i've had six
bucks at my house for
two months now and i've always been like
no no no no we're bringing the box
yeah actually i got one in the car i've
got which flavor though
[ __ ] i just want to try to see peanut
butter chocolate don't do it i'm telling
you go run and grab it if it's
if it's frosted or the fruity yeah the
fruity tastes just like fruit loops
really it has a really good that was my
shirt that should go hard in the paint
because a bunch of companies now are
doing that where they're making like
healthier
protein version snacks like they have
hot cheeto puffs but a keto version get
the [ __ ] in my face
you want the real cheetos you don't want
no [ __ ] dude last
so we're on we started game me my girl
started game of thrones two weeks ago
we're on season
halfway through season four now we've
been we're so [ __ ] good the second
time through yeah
bro she got those flaming hot uh funyuns
mm-hmm but she's eating them they're
like the oh and you hate the chewing
sounds oh you can hear
oh my god i missed the entire
and i go how how much longer you have
with those trips you excuse me i go
you can eat those chips the entire
season or how because i'm gonna throw
the [ __ ] chips
i was going no i'm sorry i was like oh
my god
oh my god this guy with the eating there
was one time we were
we were i think we were coming back we
were coming back from some city and we
were uh
in the airport and i bought some mints
and usually with mints i i put like
three of them in
but one of them i'll just like eat the
others i'll just let dissolve
and i took a bite out of one and
literally he was like
i don't know like literally at the end
of the row and this [ __ ] looked
at me like
oh dude and i took one i didn't think
anyone heard it
i took one bite immediately
yeah it's a condition mesothelioma yep
oh no mesothelioma is called misophonia
misophonia it's misophonia
oh dude it's dude like that that theater
marina where they where they offer food
yeah i pray to the gods above the
theater gods nobody orders the
chip or or or or the no jesus christ you
have so much want
to order the chips or the vegetable tray
you can't order the carrots
oh you're probably gonna have all the
flavors one of my friends has that
condition
a lot of people do that shepherd has it
my brother has it i have it mm-hmm
have you heard stevie eat the pretzel
sticks yes
yes i have i know it drives you in oh
yeah
ask him last time he was on the road i
was like no we went in the grocery store
you can't have those
dude find another place to stay because
i can't eat those in my place
right he goes hard it'll ruin my day man
it's a real condition oh gosh oh what's
that that's the fruity
that's the fruity oh no no those are
blueberry oh you know
you haven't had the blueberry get those
out of my face no you don't like
blueberry
i don't like new stuff what else what's
the other one that's true you don't know
you gotta try this
i'm telling you you grew up with
blueberry cereal i like blueberry stuff
in general yeah blueberries blueberry
what like they're called blueberries
they're like count chocula it's the same
brand they come out during halloween
blueberries like a ghost and then
captain crunch oops all berries
no say less dude how about when lucky
charms went hey you kids like
marshmallows how about arma
all marshmallows it will ruin your teeth
it tastes like you're chewing chalk but
that's pretty fantastic
that's peanut butter get on my face man
what's the other one
there's fruity and peanut butter i'm
telling you let me let
let her try the uh blueberry you want to
try a blueberry sure
i'm telling you this should go hard to
paint are you all like you look you you
you
since you've got with stevie you've lost
like a ton of weight yeah oh yeah
absolutely
i'm not uh depression eating anymore i
know i feel like your depression was
because you didn't have a merry
christmas
it could be it could be you haven't had
a touch of the dog as dove davidoff
calls it since you got with stevie
true true takes good care of me
merry christmas thank you i'm telling
you it's legit cereal
i was super suspect let me try it this
tastes just like normal cereal this
doesn't taste like healthy
also everyone's aware magic swing is not
a sponsor it's not nice like the best ad
ever
price should
should be a sponsor because i'm obsessed
with the cereal oh sorry oh no
i know you know who started doing like
those healthy like uh snacks like you
get healthy peanut butter cups
is quest oh yeah quest is a big healthy
peanut butter do you know that stevie
would have a protein ice cream company
before he went to prison
and he would have the protein ice cream
underneath you'd have drugs
yeah yep that that was like his front
yeah but oh you're not going to go
unsure that's why i went to prison for
seven years he was supposed to go to a
shark tank
and uh sell his product he was gonna go
legit
but then they found out that he was
getting indicted by the fbi and didn't
have him
and then he went to prison and he had a
trademark for protein
that ran out while he was in prison so
shortly after he came out a bunch of
people were doing the ice
the protein is like the halo tops and
stuff because his trademark that's what
handle top
is yeah like protein yeah protein ice
cream sounds brilliant yeah so you could
have been like a multi-millionaire if
you just did that instead of drugs i
know we probably told you the old school
final kid listening to this but before
quest was like quest quest
before we signed with on it because of
aubrey and uh rogan
quest brought me and brian callen into
their headquarters in kind of marina del
rey apply this area they brought us
there
and they're sitting us down their
pitches on us thinking they're like
we're just waiting for the boss you know
and we'll make the offer because we made
some crazy demands like
this huge amount of money that we wanted
because right when firing kids getting
started
so like we're just waiting for our boss
to come in and then the deal should be
done
so we've agreed to basically we've
agreed to face everything
we're like oh cool so we're like
shooting the [ __ ] and the guy's taking
forever the guy walks in
and he has a two-page one but the toupee
it's like
the worst toupee i've ever seen in your
life and he had like this horrible spray
tan
but his toupee looked like a pittsburgh
steelers helmet it was
slick and like like the fakest thing
i've seen
when i and i looked at one look at brian
and and i go
in front of where i go got a set of hair
on you dude
dude me and brian were laughing hey we
could not it was one of those times we
could not stop laughing
brian had tears coming out of his eyes
and the guy's like trying to get all
serious she goes
what do you fellas keep laughing at and
i go oh that that
bag over there is [ __ ] creepy looking
we can't stop laughing someone get the
bag out of it because guys we gotta
finish this meeting
dude we can't stop laughing i think he
became aware of what we were laughing at
ruin the deal oh really offers the deal
no thanks god because we went
on it but you could not say we lost the
deal he could not stop laughing
first of all he came in let it go dude
right when he killed a set of hair on
you
all the employees start were like
laughing and then brian
lost his [ __ ] yeah we lost him i was
surprised he didn't hear it
he probably heard it was it was the
worst toupee best in your life
i'm telling you it was a [ __ ] he
looked like sonic's the hedgehog
it's like just a [ __ ] black helmet
up here just [ __ ] yo it was so funny
it didn't look like hair brother [ __ ]
toupee man let that [ __ ] go
god it was great i don't know why people
all those are better than this oh wow
they don't look like any of that
i'm telling you so he had like a og
toupee he had not not these modern
toupees were they
no no they really look like it's no you
had a [ __ ] party
a black helmet on and it was so shiny
he said get the bag out of here oh dude
is that close to it
that that looks that looks a hundred
times better than that guys
i love just letting it go that looks way
better
i'm telling you i've never seen
something it was the worst and he's a
[ __ ] millionaire just had the worst
two people [ __ ] see in your life
gag or real life
brian count has the same hair as paulo
costa so that's cool
he should just let it like i don't just
bake it like yeah shaved yeah
yeah he looks good you watch the fights
or you see nothing yeah i know i i i saw
the uh
o'malley versus uh i don't know how to
say latino christ
chris yeah i saw that uh billy eilish
here
same here that's pretty funny because i
didn't even think about that he was a
badass but uh
yeah that was a good fight man you only
saw that one
i saw that one i saw uh the the russian
girl
versus the girl from mexico yeah i'm all
set no i i
had to go do uh do a spot and then
what did i see another one you didn't
want to wait it out i didn't see you
honestly hard
greg hardy is his name greg hardy yeah i
missed that one
um you didn't see gilbert and wonder boy
no i didn't yes he does how was that
fight
i mean if you're a gilbert fan fantastic
but oh not the best fight
was it like the most entertaining uh mac
i saw the max griffin he
and carlos connor was a good fight yeah
that was a good fight
i'm trying to think who else he saw
where'd you watch this i saw some at my
boy toby's house
i stopped by there before i went and did
uh i had to go do a spot
at this spot called ouino vino and then
you have spots uh this
yeah in uh baltimore baltimore maryland
it should be fun who's going with you
uh one of my buddies that's already out
on these east coast so easy to use he's
in new york
yeah he's in new york let me down
yeah you got a tattoo on my chest oh
recently
yeah on thursday let me see it this [ __ ]
hurts
i'm not taking you can you play with
never can you
can you pull it down i would never how
bad did it hurt on the chest
the worst i heard i heard the sternum
the throat
are the worst like yeah in the foot
because i have i have tattooed like i
have
you know stuff on my like my collarbone
you know i have like one right here
but there's just something about right
here the sternum
it's just like what's it say fttw fttw
for the thick women really yeah
faster than the world that's a band punk
rock [ __ ]
it's a song and an album and how big is
it uh it's not crazy big
like like if you like here uh no no it's
just like it's more like chesapeake
area a big dog no because i have so much
already
no my bad oh my bad fitness
aren't you getting one across your
stomach too yeah but i got i can't i
can't do that right now
you know what i mean see sometimes when
if if i was like really fat i'd get
my entire body tatted up because you
can't tell you're just like
you guys had it up like the first thing
is the tats you don't see his gut
unless you're like oh like in like like
tied to avasta looks sick he has the
tattoos on the side but he has a big
yeah
uh i guess yeah we're actually brought
to his kind of way out
it's like five seven four hundred pounds
at one time though
he's not that short he's so short really
yeah he might be five five five six what
he's super short oh and maddie too
oh yeah you guys look cool it helps
cover up actually it looks dumb you look
cool when you cover that
that's kind of like how my body like not
my that's not my body
but like as far as like the tats on it
it's just like all random
[ __ ] it's not like an old school sailor
yeah none of it's like uh
for um like any [ __ ] specific piece
there's just all one theme that's all
punk rock
it's all punk rock except for my city
and then a homie that passed away that's
on that side yeah
you can all blast it up who did it same
guy yeah my boy dan smith
and that hurt down and uh aren't you
you're getting sleeved up cat yeah i
want to sleep
i just you want hard to paint i want to
finish the rest of my arm i just don't
know who to go to because my
current tattoo artist is booked up and
then he goes back to china for like a
year
well that's so easy oh yeah i mean
you could check his work first before
you know but i'll throw my guy uh
yeah i don't know what to get though
that's the thing because i don't want
anything specific i just want a dope
sleeve
i just want them to finish it so it
looks coherent that's it you gotta pick
some theme and then let them design yeah
i want something asian oh okay yeah
like a koi fish no like an asian style
like sleeve
uh like like a like a geisha mask you
want some evil [ __ ]
you want a ninja i do like something a
little more like
uh a little hard i don't like things
that are a lot too wide
right too feminine yeah i want black and
gray asians don't get koi fish
unfortunately oh i thought it was just
like white oh my god
white people do get them
damn would you ever do something like
that cat uh not that much i would want
sleeves i'd want
like a leg sleeve too but i don't know
if my whole body
it looks dope though damn girl yeah damn
girl what's
up what is that flower called that
everyone gets a lot of people get that
cherry blossom
is that what it is damn that's
that bro this is like my whole style
back get this off
yeah all those [ __ ] what where's your
guy he's out in tustin it's called
capture
tattoo my boy dan smith really really
really
really
really
really
really really
really
really
really
really really
really
really
really
really really
really
really
really
really really
really
really
really
really really good
artist yeah very famous yeah he used to
roll uh
kat von d yeah used to be oh yeah that
was really really
la inc yeah yeah he's really really good
i heard kat von d
like still i think she's 1600 an hour
jesus christ like super expensive well
also makes sense she has her
she had her black and white style yeah
her shop's still there i've
seen it like open voltage yeah yeah
right up on uh
[Music]
yeah kat von d was so big she was
i have a i went to miami inc when i was
a broke college well i was transitioned
from college to the nfl
had no money right and didn't play in
the nfl but uh
uh when i was transitioning i went to uh
miami inc me and my best friend clap
went to miami i went to miami
they were such dicks oh really were they
and now the famous people are in there
just like
all like whoever mm-hmm yeah they were
not oh [ __ ] someone just came to me what
bro uh my buddy i haven't watched it yet
my buddy was telling me about this show
it's called have you heard of it love
after lockup
no yeah on netflix yeah it's i don't
know if it's on netflix convicts who get
out and find love
or they they have love while they're in
there or something like that but do they
get out because i don't want to watch
them
i don't watch a [ __ ] show and they're
calling in the whole time no no no i
think they get out too
it's on we tv it's on we tv wait yeah
how are we supposed to watch it what the
[ __ ] we tv sometimes that's what it
takes to learn from your mistakes
no i want like a real [ __ ] but my boy a
real criminal my boy was telling me some
no no this sounds like all the time
that's not it that's not it that's why
like killers this one's called love
after logo that's life this is life
after lockup
so here it is dude someone oh look at
that toupee i know
oh you're just on it oh wow so some
like uh i guess there's girls out there
that will
like scam prisoners basically and make
them their
sugar daddy but the prisoners have no
money they get money in there
they can get money well not like tons of
money right i get i guess like lost
yeah yeah because the girl you don't
have to do anything
homeboy is locked up you're sending some
ass pics and writing notes yeah that's
all you got to do
yeah i guess there's of a lot of that
goes down on like
this show they should put that uh
security guard and [ __ ] the homies oh my
god she should have her own show
that's really what it is [ __ ] the homies
she let all 11 watch
a little update on that later oh you
have an update well hopefully it's a
real one but i'll
show you later [ __ ] wayne damn
you found out the print what the
prisoner looked like no i wish i could
ah there's still no that's what i want
to see no you'll be happy with this
though oh okay
it'll be rewarding yeah and i'm sure for
one of your current events you have that
uh the denver thing the all-star game no
did you guys see that so they they uh
i guess hotel employees saw these guys
coming in
like with curious [ __ ] so they called
the cops dude
they were playing like the las vegas
shooting
during the all-star game and shoot out
the windows and kill people and they
busted it
how this doesn't get more coverage is
insane to me
wow for us after the maven which is
right across from coors field that
actually stayed there that's what they
were planning to shoot up the all-star
game
it's a pretty nice hotel too yeah it's
[ __ ] great
how terrible is that [ __ ] how does
this not get more coverage those guys
should i mean i know they're doing their
job but still man
and it's just horrible friday yeah is
that crazy
my parents are actually going to the
home run derby today it would be a hard
pass for me
the home run home run derby you guys are
both dying up there
i don't know what the hell i was sick
all last week
i'm good i thought it was allergies i
can't figure it out i'm better now
though
i don't know what it is that's when you
get dude when you got kids and you
he got something from one of those
[ __ ] slimy kids at school and he
comes home with a cop
the whole house is sick for two weeks
everybody the heat [ __ ] me up this
weekend
you're from phoenix yeah but it's still
really hot is hot dog yeah you're right
how did especially i mean i'm
dark-skinned dawg
yeah the sun's just hanging out with me
but yeah you don't know you don't feel
good in heat
never never have never have never have
since i was a kid
i like to eat i beat really eat all yes
i like all the time pass out king in the
heat
that's dawg yeah um
yeah man i don't mind the heat all right
jim what do you got summer summer time
summer's here kids and there's never
been a better time to try a shirt from
ontucket they have performance shirts
that wick the sweat
when you app out there flipping burgers
cutting up them sausages on that hot ass
grill man you need something slick you
need something on tucked you need on
tuck it
shirts the perfect shirt as we
transition
back into normal life we're leaving
covid you're having dinner with friends
you're barbecuing you're reuniting with
family there's vacations
use code fighter for 20 off your first
purchase at ontucket.com
untuck it make sure it's designed to be
untucked for god's sakes figure it out
they have fits for all shapes and sizes
ontucket offers up to size
xxl for you super thicks out there plus
they have slim
relaxed and tall for you tall boys plus
they have slim relax
tall fits we got it all ontalkit has 85
stores nationwide
use code fighter for 20 off your first
purchase at ontucket.com
man maybe you and your girl are into
some show right now i'm watching
game of thrones for the second time
through and there's nothing better maybe
your balls deep in yellowstone
and you're like you know what man i
don't feel like leaving the crib right
now to stop my favorite show but i need
food i'm starving
i've built up an appetite watching the
lannisters take over the kingdoms i've
built up an appetite
watching these white walkers eat people
i've built up an appetite but i want to
leave my crib
that's where grubhub got you covered man
grubhub works hard to serve restaurants
so they can
work hard to serve you your favorite
restaurants need you right now
that's where grubhub comes into place
and grubhub is doing an exclusive deal
right now with panera all right
today grubhub's doing a little extra to
serve panera
get free delivery perk on your first
order from panera 15
or more order through the grubhub app or
online grubhub we serve restaurants
all right first one what you starting us
with okay
so a woman was duct taped to a chair in
first class
on her flight because she had a mental
breakdown so she needed to get off
of the plane and mid-flight she tried to
open up the door clearly it wasn't going
to open but they couldn't get her
to calm down so they duct tape her and
this is the photo
first of all who took that [ __ ] phone
i know it's the worst this is the worst
photo
how do you not get a better shot all
this technology out there and so they
just duct tape their mouth into
yeah for the rest of the flight nor you
can do they can do whatever they have
no that i don't know what the protocol
is for somebody who's who has duct tape
on a [ __ ] flight
i guess the stewardess did maybe i could
see don't fly
it was i called this [ __ ] i'm a duct
taper i know don't
they duct tape your mouth too guy on
there marshall one marshall yeah i don't
know
they say that sometimes and sometimes
work on i always think oh they probably
think i'm in the marshall
in my head i'm like no because there's a
whole process if [ __ ] did go down
they do go on because there's a whole
process they have to go through before
they even get on the plane
i met a martial one time you tell me how
boring it is because nothing ever
happened i mean obviously september
obviously horrible yeah but now nothing
ever happens
yeah i mean with them i got to save this
song stewardess might get punched in the
face because of the
nazis but yeah
as a martial oh no it was it was an old
jeju coach his name was neil mal
uh malison and he's going blind but he
was like
a beast and he was a martial he's like
dude it's so [ __ ] boring
according to howl air marshall flight
each day on domestic international
flights dude
international okay you're going to
england i know can you imagine hey
you're going to [ __ ] dubai and back
bubba
uh however because undercover is part of
the jobs pick number air marshals and
what flights are deployed on are
considered sense of security information
so they yeah they can't be on every
fight i'll go to that one how often is
the air marshal on the flight
do all flights have air marshals know
the united states less than one less
than one wow
oh wow well think about 44 000
commercials too many
every day one person god damn but i
always assume
i was getting like i know i look like
there marshall
what's up i would do some [ __ ] if it
went down though
i know you i live for that moment what
else you got jen
so this one is unfortunate but on friday
night at knott's berry farm there was a
drive-by
shooting uh i believe two people were
hit
and they were taken to the hospital they
were
i think young adults like 18
19 year old there was drive-by shooting
that happened at the very front so
people who were walking out were trying
to get into the park were
all scrambling that's buena park yeah
boynton park once last time went to
knott's berry farm though
years ago it is actually 2011. yep don't
ever go
10 years ago i went me my girl went
years ago probably eight years ago
before
kids it was so [ __ ] ratchet first of
all
their main theme you know how like
universal studios has like
[ __ ] the avengers and like
you know disneyland clearly has [ __ ]
mickey mouse and all the pigs are
characters
knott's berry has charlie brown yes
snoopy
so mike was that the peanuts are they
going when have the penis been relevant
in the last
30 [ __ ] years so my kid gets so he's
like what the [ __ ] is this dude i'm like
i don't know what to tell you don't they
still show that peanuts christmas or
something like that
charlie brown christmas oh is that what
it is i think that's what it is they did
do the movie my son was in it for a
while
remember they redid the movie there was
like a whole straight up movie probably
like five years ago
the charlie brown story it was like a
real legitimate my dad would love that
movie
you how old do that 50. there you go
that's the point they need that's very
funny they do something who's still
rolling out to knox very farm though
i've been wanting to go i've been
fighting that's so funny that this
happens because i was
just running the whole girl what go to
sixth grade go to magic man because it's
so
so close and it's just like a fun you
know like a little back experience it's
okay there no it's
not no it's not it's when we bring in
alcohol we bring an alcohol
we'll sneak it in and because we can
sneak into six flags and go on some big
boy roller coaster
[ __ ] it's just too far of a drive bro
you get drunk and get on a roller
coaster when you get drunk at disneyland
struggle
sober on a road you can get yeah me too
i can't i gotta take drive i mean
i'm getting old uh you get alcohol in
california you don't have to sneak in
you don't know but
it's so expensive we just bring it out
like we bring wow
you can never think about getting on the
ride yeah because at disney world
or disneyland you can order bear and
ships yeah i don't think there's hard
enough no
there's there's yeah there is at
california california is more for adults
and then disney is for the kids yeah
they might be adventure yeah oh but but
doesn't
disneyland has that where the house of
blues is that that that area yeah the
yeah
outside the park you mean the disney
world they have tony roma's they have
starbucks yeah they have like it's like
the adult area this is the
downtown disney area so i was i went to
a place called pleasure
island in disney world which was all
like bars
it was like a fun dancing place or you
know bar dancing places
i just drank what are called strength
there it's like clubs nightclubs i
don't think it's still there it's one or
one of those places yeah
yeah wow dude go to you take your girls
six flags man
it's just too far but of course first of
all you're or you're hey
hey cheapskate you ready i know it's on
groupon whatever two tickets for thirty
dollars
there's a reason for that you're saving
money because you're [ __ ] hiding
alcohol into the park and then parking's
like seven dollars
here's the other thing the roller
coasters made out of wood
i know what dude and it shakes like this
that one in knott's berry yeah yeah yeah
yeah
that one's a beast cause like this don't
[ __ ] you up makes you all sore and [ __ ]
cause you feel like you're getting beat
up
especially and i think that's the roller
coaster it's either that's
six flags or not spray farm that's the
one on step by step you remember when it
shows the whole family on the
poster mm-hmm
well no six flags might have the biggest
uh six flags
there's magic mountain yeah there you go
how far is that from yeah where's the
magic mountain not too bad valencia
not too bad how and a half no is that oh
for an hour and a half
for me maybe 45 minutes yeah from
calabash yeah it's pretty far it's it's
definitely a trick traffic isn't
terrible no there's no traffic
traffic going to orange county is
terrible it's going to take you longer
to get to the raspberry farm even though
it's closer i think what we're going to
do is we're going to uber from her place
to nazareth so don't worry about driving
yeah because we're going to drink
[ __ ] up yeah dude i'm not looking at
that
ratchet have you guys ever done that no
no it'll make the experience so much
more fun believe me i hate roller
coasters
i mean obviously you not gonna i love
you i'm sick i don't know i just guess
yeah
that's my thing with wrong take driving
i can only handle two
i told you when me j and stevie when we
were in i think santa you guys went to
three
right we went to matt we went to magic
uh
six flags out there yeah we bought the
fast pass we went on
two roller coasters and then we're like
let's get out of
yeah i don't definitely want to drink
alcohol i'm telling you it works
even you're not going to get sick on the
rise it makes you feel more relaxed and
chill
it's just by the way i'm not encouraging
people to drink alcohol no well
if you do drink you encourage them to
drink and sneak it into the air
if you're a drinker then try it i'm
gonna touch it there's not enough
alcohol on earth to make knottsberry
farm fun i know it's just like a it
reminds me of that one
like shoots up real tall and then
[ __ ] drops hard yeah
yeah yeah accelerator accelerator
the ghost rider they have new roller
coasters now yeah i remember this one oh
yeah
they don't service them i don't trust
any of that [ __ ] you got a 16 year old
being like
being like pressing the button you tell
me that kid you're gonna leave your
[ __ ] life in that kid's hands
i used to love that one ride that would
like swing like that
and turn i don't know what it's called
it's like the ship i think it's
over there it's called the lav
revolution or something like that so
it's knott's berry farm just roller
coasters
no no they have all [ __ ] they have a
cool halloween night there
oh yeah they're they're not universal
that's not scary for them nightmare
literally it's like there's two killing
people you go on one haunted house for
seven hours for the haunted houses it's
even tough
i've been to disneyland
disney halloween's dope it's like a
three-hour wait for the haunted mansion
that's too much i've been a disney
christmas that one's pretty dope that's
great i like that's [ __ ] special
nothing beats disney
i like yeah i like that i had a good
time with my chef kids
for scaring or scary stuff but i mean
just to feel good
like oh yeah the memories of christmas
it's awesome over there yeah
we'll have fun with charlie brown all
right thank you drunk off your ass
hope you at least have good whiskey man
i'll give you a box take a bottle from
the studio
oh you guys already discussed this right
yeah yeah with it without finding this
girl
look at him standing behind her mm-hmm
let's take a look
that's nice you think all they did was
just the date i can see her titties from
here
run on third day slime oh she had a
dodgers jersey i don't do how awkward is
that guy i know that's so weird
does he refills like no he's right there
yeah he's gonna hear everything god what
a [ __ ] date man how do
you top that anyway she dates yeah how
do you [ __ ] top that way to go
drake drake out here making it difficult
i think that's the point though
yeah it's drake it's drake he's my
friend he can do that
good for him okay so a few things about
the story first and foremost uh
there is a woman this beautiful blonde
woman apparently she's 26 according to
the story i
she's 46 years old yeah i don't know why
they list her as 26 i think they just
got it wrong
but she is a mother of two living
in i believe australia hell yeah she got
a note from her neighbor saying
basically hey when you're passing by
your windows
put on some clothes because my kids
don't want to see your ass
oh yeah and she got really weirded out
by this because
she said the only time she could
remember recently ever being in a
situation where her ass was out was late
at night when she was
turning off the lights trying to go to
bed she had a t-shirt on and panties
i guess like the bottom of her ass cheek
was no she didn't even say it was a
thong she said
she called them french panties i don't
know what that means but
it sounded like booty shorts like her
butt was sticking out at the bottom
yeah and a neighbor left a note after
her house two young boys
i don't know why would they snitch on
this lady dude what are you guys doing
man
no the husband wrote that no it could be
i feel like it's probably the white
would be much appreciated if you could
at least shut your blinds when working
naked walking naked
around your house my kids do not my kids
do not and would not
like to see your ass out on the sh
much appreciated your neighbors with a
peace sign
that's her yeah that's her dude i've
been [ __ ] stoked as a young man
[Laughter]
oh she's probably around 26 years she's
uh she's not she's a mother of
uh two yeah and she's 40 i don't think
she's 26 i also don't think she's 46 i
feel like she's probably somewhere
within her like
early 40s like late 30s
but she looks amazing this is in the uk
i get it i guarantee the next door
neighbor the wife is
the wife is busted and insecure nope
that's okay oh she's from the uk you're
right in australia
dude how about my [ __ ] england team
lost no [ __ ]
euro cup are you devastated baby what
i said italy baby how are you
going to fight everybody how italian are
you i'm full
your dad was born and raised there oh no
his grandparents were
and my dad on my mom's side her
parents were or but your parents were
both born here
yeah you're american italian yeah okay
were you born in the uk his mom was
but i'm also like 10 of talent oh yeah
yeah
so when what do you know a part no clue
i i'm trying to do the family tree thing
there's an app you can download it's a
[ __ ] nightmare
i don't know if i trust any of that it'd
be cool they're just trying to make
money
yeah like how accurate you know pretty
accurate
i did it and it was the biggest waste of
money ever i know it just told me i was
vietnamese that's it and my mom thought
i was a [ __ ]
idiot no i do i want to try it because i
don't want to do the family tree thing
so you can go all the way back like so
you can find like different processors
yeah some cool [ __ ] but you have to have
like death certificates i'm like what
the [ __ ]
you can do with the elvis if your family
came over to ellis island
you can go on the website through there
and find it through there but
if you know when your family came over
you can find i have no clue when they
came out that's why i'm [ __ ] paying
these man
she lives here she passed away but oh
she passed she lived in england until
she was
20 something 27. my my mom lived in
england until she was like in her teens
wow all my aunts and uncles too does she
still have an accent
a little bit my aunt full full does and
then my grandma
did for i mean since i was a kid yeah
yeah that's why i root for england and
they [ __ ] lost man
okay so i don't know how legit this is
but someone sent it to me and this is
apparently that girl
the corrections officer wow tough times
don't last tough people do
so she has 36 thousand followers now but
yeah and i wonder i do wonder
is this possibly a girl that kind of
looks like her and is trying to profit
off of it i don't know
but she has her like donation thing here
at yg yeah it's called free tina but
this is other pictures there's a body
picture here which is
pretty good that's her it's rocking that
sra that's right hashtag
hashtag hustle hard someone put them
boys got lucky
i agree oh wait go oh
it says bomb let me get oh my god how
dare you
keep squad uh that's supposed to be i
checked it out that's her dad apparently
okay and then you know just like the
other pictures she does have
brunette here in the earlier pictures so
i don't know
that might be her man could be if that's
her then she looks way better than i
thought oh i always thought she was a
dog no she looked amazing but you know
there's different angles and stuff
but wait where did it happen at good
question or camera
cause because does she have a kitchen
scroll down that'd be such a [ __ ]
because the gear she's rocking is like a
southern california like
gear well said swag i don't know it
could be someone else's kid
that's a cute-ass kid dude scroll down
her dad with tony hawk oh okay let's see
here this might be real
uh scroll up for me chin up the white
and black hand
black out tuesday your struggle is my
struggle
blackout tuesday and then the next
poster our next post is this
hermosa i've seen a lot of first 48 i
would assume
that that guy who ran the the train on
her black fella black yeah
hell yeah taking a while gus and this
makes it hotter rolling the dice
yeah this is fair oh and she's wearing a
lot of uh
that beanie she's got on that's why g's
uh oh so she's a yg fan
yeah fo hunnit that's why g's uh
clothing line oh there you go she
probably orders only dark meat when she
goes
you catch my drift there and then also a
super timepiece
god doug also worth the headache also
who
the frog hired her to work a present i
don't know
someone said arrest me i was caught
shoplifted
lock me up throw away
1800 likes i'm not letting any other cop
arrest me until she gets here
for you i don't know she'd be free i
don't know if she should be locked up i
don't know
her dad clearly a troll from the show
trolls so that's cool
that's fantastic her dad is spot-on
[ __ ] that's cool god damn she's a small
so
yeah maybe her potentially i mean so she
have a man now or
is that her man but yeah well cause he's
in prison he can't be taking
shots i saw one dude still technically
married because remember in the article
she said that she was going through
marital problems there's no picture of a
man
i saw one photos see if her man had
tagged her in anything oh exactly
there's one here
damn you get down on this brother
brother brother being my bbw
partner what what's bw
oh yeah terrible
how about buffalo oh she's a ufc fan too
look at this and guess what we just had
cody on
i cannot believe i'm about to see this
in person goddammit 2016.
do you like the fight game on man right
that's my ear
wow it gets deeper and deeper yeah look
at this conor mcgregor
2016. dave and busters she didn't win
that but
the d and b's that dmg these pickles too
mm-hmm yeah do a christmas show
photos which tag photos hey there wait
there's a dude there's a dude
the dirt no no that's what he's a famous
he's a motorcyclist
motocross yeah he's dope
i think this is probably her page huh
i'm about donate some money to her so
that was the one that we saw already
okay you guess
okay she's you know she's gonna have a
career after this
oh absolutely assume but what does the
mug shot look like
in comparison like put those that's her
dog you you think it's fully her
husband lamar that's [ __ ] i've seen
it i've done some research
that's her let me see here corrections
it's just to be the hottest correction
officer all the time dude on worldstar
let's show these cops
some of these cops like what the [ __ ] is
that her dude that's her that's just a
terrible picture
it does look like her though i mean
especially in the like these that's her
but i don't know if it's a hundred
percent her dude that's 110 percent look
at the makeup there
and look at the makeup in the other and
that's her getting busted after getting
railed by [ __ ] the homies
and she's [ __ ] she didn't get caught
immediately
we don't know that it really does look
like her though
i think it's her yeah most likely we
just don't know
uh let's see hustle 23 hard
well hustle hard girl it's tina g23
she's only doing two years
mind your own business you'll live
longer oh she's she needs a pen pal
gladly that's not her that's not her
uh christian you're you're you're too
light in the ass for her and you're also
not black
two strikes bubba the third one
do you know a lawyer i do you do yeah
that might help you
what else you got uh this is thank you
takashi
sent that to us god damn it i know i'll
find out who the name is later
takashi 69 is trolling that guy blue
face because he had this crazy
like head tattoo that most likely was
something that
he did it for money or for jewelry
they're like hey man
can you do an instagram post you're like
how about i just get don't do it like
that
oh yeah he was like how about i just
tattoo your uh store name on my head
he's got quite a few on there yeah but
the name of the wrong name of the
jewelry store
oh and it sounds like he's not doing
well why too much financially because
he's taking that celebrity bare knuckle
match which is crazy enough
with that random tick tocker yeah and
he's doing this cringe
and he yelled in that tick tocker's face
and he goes
yeah i know i know we just passed the
hustle hard girl but i just went through
her stories and
she has a adopted jail bill for for
honor stories
would it be worth it uh yeah go
has a what scroll up to the lipstick one
we gotta get this girl out of prison
show me some love
oh my god box
i'll go back now in that shop right now
go back to what one
that was 65 weeks ago no no no that
hit my cash app five days ago commentary
close phone lawyer fees uh i love her
you love her i love her
uh she's gonna be perfectly fine i'm
sure yeah i bet she's gonna be fine
we've talked about her every week out
here she's gonna be the female
uh felon bae remember the guy with the
light eyes who became a model yeah
he had a girl that he was with he had a
wife when he uh went in and
got famous and then shortly after he
started dating the heiress
to the top shop uh empire yeah
and his wife found out that he was
dating her
on the internet and then they got
divorced shortly after and she threw a
she did a club appearance shortly after
saying like oh i'm divorced do they have
kids
yeah i think two yeah
she was pretty hot too right she's very
good-looking his wife
his ex-wife um
that was her on the left
she's better looking than his curt one
but the current one's stupid stupid
what does the current one look like
right there
oh she's gorgeous
she's a pretty girl yeah we'll leave it
at that
well he's there by looking at the right
one at least they're doing it
all right this is from fourth of july
but i thought this was crazy
some douchebags threw a firecracker into
someone's convertible
luckily this guy's fine
[Music]
well he just did it just yeah just being
dicks in that car right there yeah yeah
so hopefully they'll find him because
they got the license plate here the guy
that was recording just has a dash cam
and it's one of his buddies
and check it out here
oh no jesus christ man what's the point
just to be dicks [ __ ] it hit that guy in
the head yeah yeah and then
did that so he probably wanted this
thing's probably on the right so he's
safe
oh he was reaching for it too yeah he
said he burned two of his fingers trying
to get it out
i don't get it man i hope they caught
the [ __ ] me too what's the
point look at that
geez [ __ ] that guy what's the point
probably just some young stupid kids yep
jesus christ someone actually threw a
freaking m80
in my gym bathroom when i was taking a
leak that's hilarious no it's not
hilarious it was like right next to me
in the toilet
so of course it just boom water splashed
up and i'm peeing i have no idea
and i just went deaf completely deaf and
i was freaked i was so freaked out that
i could lost my husband he was in school
yeah i couldn't hear for like a minute
and then slowly came back
yeah but still yeah [ __ ]
adults um
i just saw this recently pfizer
says their vaccine isn't doing so well
so they're asking for people to get a
coveted booster shot
but then cdc says we don't need the
booster that's just
hype to push the to more more vaccines
more funny for it that's all they just
push and push it
yeah they just you know
i saw this on barstool i will just play
it
she's about to kill her she begged for a
diaper
so when you lie on the application to
get the job
even the sound of the board too big
to be diving like that she might have
been really good but just not one time
this is also crazy but too calm for the
situation
there's a mo there's a mother bear with
cubs and this guy's like just talking
about it and realizes she has cubs
of course reading a book and
hello what's up
he's like you didn't get yes i know see
there's little babies they're usually
super protective of these
there are little babies oh they're cute
as [ __ ]
you want to touch its nose no oh my god
oh the
cubs i do yeah holy cow kids are doing
whatever they want for the gram
these are so cute
they are cute as [ __ ] god he's so
[ __ ] lucky
all righty i'm sure you guys heard this
song yet alright
i haven't heard this okay let's go and
play it real quick it's [ __ ]
this is to get people vaccinated oh yeah
this is so dope
i'm not sure how much you're gonna play
this but they recorded an entirely new
video for this one
who's the fat guy manny french fresh
what
[Laughter]
does anybody watch this be like man you
know what i know
who's like man how can we get the black
community to get more vaccinated you
know what i call it
juveniles call it juvenile right now
they i bet you they went through a list
of celebrities before he was like i'll
do it
juvenile was on top of the world at one
point too remember when it's superheroes
hot second yeah the hot boys where's the
hub hot boys yeah
that's where lil wayne comes from that's
right all those guys this is pretty
jacked up
um this is a rutgers receiver named
carnell davis
he was playing i don't want to show the
video yet but oh he was playing a
football on the beach with this guy
and they got into an argument so they
brought it to the street here and then i
guess the other guy said something about
carnell's mom so that's how this started
and i'll show you what happens
arnold's on the blue shorts relax relax
just oh oh my wow yeah
that was a hit hard what happened to him
they said he's recovering at home with
his family he looks like the dorkiest
receiver on the team
he doesn't look like a street fighter
kind of guy but it happened
he got mad because the dude said
something about his mom he looks like a
street fighter type of guy
he doesn't look like a street fighter
neither of them do yeah well especially
this guy
this guy looks like she's innocent yeah
[ __ ]
it's like that went to touring yeah dawg
he got
dropped his head's alright yeah i know
that's like that could be life-changing
right there's somebody you're going to
[ __ ] my mom
the guy's like yeah i did dude and then
he knocked him out
oh jesus christ that ain't how that's
supposed to go
no you know what i'm saying supposed to
be like oh yeah
you know he's supposed to get him but
yeah
and uh how cool is this just check it
out this is how they stock fish in utah
i did see this
do all the fish survive this jump that's
right okay when i first saw it i'm like
there's got to be a ton that dies but
like
they said less than one percent die
they're lying to you no because they're
baby fish yeah
they're not like all right let's go
ahead and judge it go ahead and judge
yourself without playing this [ __ ]
hype let me know it works out for you
[Music]
the fish are like what the [ __ ] it's so
high it's so high
dude none of those fish are survived
look how high that is that that was
pretty high
and then the impact of the water you
think they're just okay when they smack
into the water that's how small they are
and how do they know
that they survive they go in there look
for it that's a good question dude
but it just looks like it's way too high
and that water looks pretty shallow yeah
it is
those fish are like what the [ __ ] dude
wait so what's the purpose of that stock
though stocking legs because there's
the fish you know population in there is
not it's it's
declining they do it everywhere here
when you go fishing they stalk
everything
it's pretty dope mm-hmm it is pretty
cool looking
there's no way those fish aren't
concussed when they hit that fight
see i wonder how they yeah how the [ __ ]
do they find out that they survive
survival rates more than 95
i'm not buying that yeah like how do we
check how do we know
well some definitely certainly they have
to say that
yeah i would maybe use a helicopter or
something but not a
freaking plane or just use trucks and
like it's hard to get to those areas
really oh like that drives in the
mountains and stuff like that yeah
all right well yeah um
oh this one i don't know how legit this
is either but someone messaged me this
and lady with autism gets offended by a
comedian during a set she falls into his
car and punch
punches his car this is from paulo
i'll watch i'll show you this video i'm
not afraid of you
hey let the guy drive away let the
[Music]
[Applause]
how about you gather faster dude he's
probably confused but i mean i'm sure
that could happen potentially right if
you
pick a girl that has autism and you kind
of like you go on or yeah yeah
and you just don't know is that what
happened that's what they're saying
happened
i mean you just made fun of her yeah you
know like just fun
roasting but how do you know she has
autism i guess
she probably said something because she
wasn't you know but sometimes people in
the audience just say [ __ ]
yeah but that person could potentially
be autistic and then just doesn't work
out
yeah i like how they put the autism
awareness month yeah i don't know
gotcha i was like that's that i mean i
don't know that's how slow was she
back out there i've been [ __ ] out
yeah later yeah
and i thought this was nice it's not
upworthy but it's also
kind of scary so it says construction
the kids toys just make them smile and
watch
how close the kids get to this thing
[Music]
this guy's a pro yeah but would you let
tiger get this close
absolutely watch
[Applause]
yeah it's not touching it watch out oh
that's cool though it is cool
he is a perfect definitely professional
he's really good god he's [ __ ]
he's a surgeon with that thing yeah but
i'm just worried that there's a
malfunction and something happens
that's dope though man yeah that's cool
for the kids
that means
they'll remember it forever maybe
they're young though you know because
yeah
when they're young i think
well i don't want to show you this one
because it's embarrassing what but
does someone caught a trophy goldfish
and there was roastium
because it's a goldfish that's a huge
goldfish yeah but
it's not a goldfish oh it's not a
goldfish no it's still a goldfish like
you know what
going to dump it into a lake you know
when they're little tiny this one's a
[ __ ]
the teenage mutant ninja turtles i know
it's kind of embarrassing to be like the
record holder for the biggest goldfish
hey man is goldfish not like a cool
thing no because it's a there's a pet
it's just a little pet yeah they're not
that's impossible
let them have that metal
oh yeah that's dead you can't eat
goldfish i mean they're i think they
relate to carp so you can eat it but
it's so bony and no one really likes it
it's considered junk fish or trash fish
damn goldfish just get hated on
all right and then this is really
nothing but i just thought this was cool
yeah i think it's pretty [ __ ] sick so
lamborghini
they made an off-roader that thing is
filthy
the video kind of sucks though this
tires are dope
that'd be so much work whoever did that
and the cost of it too
oh my god oh damn
yeah it could definitely be in a movie
but it's just they don't do much
sounds like lambo too that's almost
balling to turn a
new landmark and they did it well too
hell yeah that thing's sick yeah
what this all the video is nothing
off-roading or anything
no one's going to want that thing i
gotta vex that thing up in my head now
[ __ ] i know it's a terrible video
it is oh one more one more
breaking news robert downey jr just
stopped following all of his uh
marvel people why friends he didn't say
so he stopped following chris evans tom
holland
i think a couple of people
that's all who noticed that did he say
no but people will find out real quick
how does it [ __ ] matter they find
that out they go through their
following they made that a headline damn
denver shooting
[ __ ] couldn't get there are crazy fans
who will uh keep track of who how many
people
uh their favorite celebrity follows and
if it goes up or down one they'll go
search
to see who it is oh wow hardcore that's
how people find stuff like this out
wow i just thought it was funny that
makes so much sense
maybe do something more with your life
than that yeah absolutely
and you know let's do one more i just
thought this was funny too because it
says
fans praise kourtney kardashian for
sharing an unedited
thong bikini photo and it's his way to
empower
i mean it's like she just looks great
she looks hot
and people are like you go girl yeah
you're brave yeah
you're so brave showing us your perfect
ass like that and heels that make no
sense while you're walking to the
pool yeah she's bodybuilding good for
trash parker
he he [ __ ] he could not
they're just happy because she didn't
photoshop it yeah
doctor it up yeah is that it that's it
all right
all right kids first sets in la this
friday saturday
uh some shows are sold out tickets still
left for some of the shows that's
this friday and saturday july 16th and
july 17th two shows 8 p.m 10 p.m
both nights friday and saturday shop and
friends at the haha
in l.a my first sets in l.a come get it
um then tacoma washington july 29th
through the 31st coma comedy club
that's thursday friday saturday in
tacoma washington then
raleigh north carolina august 19th
august 21st
la jolla comedy store those tickets
should be on sale any second waiting for
the comedy store to send me the link
august 27th
29th san jose california san jose improv
september 9th through september 11th
san antonio the big boy bud light
courtyard
uh september 24th 25th uh that's san
antonio
denver las vegas just got rescheduled
brea
las vegas brea and honolulu hawaii all
in october
tickets at thickboy.com or
love fatkz.com guys chappelle's in
baltimore this thursday friday saturday
thursday friday saturday
then august 26th bray improv and then
october
7th through the 9th i'm in tampa at side
splitters and then
later on that month october 28th through
the 30th i'll be in dc at the dc you've
been in dc before
uh yeah once it was right before [ __ ]
broke out
dc is great i love it there all right
kids
see ya